just walking around the site today it is
very different it was say 48 hours ago a
lot of the caravans have moved they
haven't moved very far and say the
majority of them have just moved next
door onto the the legal site and aren't
currently camped out there whether
they'll stay there for any length of
time though is another matter
but most of the site is is a lot clearer
in terms of caravans just around about
the same number of people because of
course a lot of activists have moved in
and they have been building more
fortifications today inside behind the
fence behind me there there's a there's
another barrier being built today with
tires and barbed wires
I'm just joined now by two people
Natalie Fox who's one of the supporters
and margaret mccarthy is one of the
residents Margit if I can ask you first
what's the mood this is your last night
on Dale farm it's the last night and the
mood here is just it's like somebody's
after dying I really can't explain to
where people really is feeling here
their heart is broken at the turn of a
community that we fight it so hard for
ten year we have pleaded and begged
resident to bill decides we were willing
need to move of offer here because there
was only an old scrap er between that
have netted the best we could and I said
it was Greenbelt so then we went with
them we had a lot of meetings and then
they said that if we found land further
afield today would help us so we don't
out put in applications and to refuse
them so I don't know what we're going to
do as people say what are you gonna do
and in terms of trying to stop the
bailiffs coming on lots of residents and
supporters are working together in order
to do civil disobedience to resist the
eviction and also for Human Rights
observing the UN has been involved and
the European Council has been involved
in lots organizations like Amnesty
International have involved they're very
concerned about violations of human
rights a lots of people are coming on to
the sites to Human Rights observing in
terms of actual physically what are you
going to do I mean can you talk about
that well a lot of preparations will be
clearer tomorrow people have been
building fortifications and people are
willing to use nonviolent direct action
strategies in order to try to push the
bailiffs off for as long as possible
Margaret's hearing today from the
council that areas around here have
increased their security to try and stop
you
guys moving on to other sites other
unauthorized sites how do you feel about
that and where do you where do you think
you are going to go that moves me
disgustin because we are traveling
people and for us to leave here we'll
have to travel and we'll have to put
onto those gates a tear blocking forgive
to do dot that means they're breaking
the law because we've nowhere to go
they're saying that were breaking the
law but at the end the idiots Tim that's
doing us their fortunes are for this
grant that we bought and paid for two
decided a road and when we put the
decided a rover still breaking the law
our trainers now going to school that's
breaking the law so why can't understand
what's going on it's I'm more confused
about distance where are you going to go
tomorrow we have to go to the side of
the road and that's it we have no other
choice we have absolutely nowhere to go
Natalie thank you very much for talking
to me as I say a lot of the caravans
have moved off and I guess there's now
just a few hours for anyone who to make
that decision as to whether they're
going to move their property off and
find somewhere else to go or whether
they're going to wait for that gate to
shut sit behind it and wait for the
bailiffs to come